not only because she's my girlfriend but
because I just love simple yeah and
that's what made me yeah choose that
oh not because I don't think highly of
myself but just because I was on a oh no
like on set with all these beautiful
women and they all have something going
on in their lives too I just feel like
I'm I'm okay with what they set me at
right shut up
we brought together five couples and had
the girlfriends rank themselves based on
how attractive they think they are then
we invited their boyfriends to rearrange
them this is ranking
hi my name is ajanae I'm 23 and I'm
and I'm a coach from Sacramento hi guys
what happened in your head like what
happened a mindset coach
I need to Google this [__] up because I
feel like every day Instagram introduced
me to new made-up professions
certified life coach I just how you
gonna be a mindset coach at 23.
see you later
right there at the end of the day I
think
life coaches is a bit of charlatanism
but that's me I'm Vera I am 23 and I am
a PhD student wow
I'm 19 and I'm a full-time college
student
I'm Jennifer I'm 26. I'm a property
manager and also upcoming real estate
agent as well hey I like this girl I
like this girl you hear it in her voice
you can tell she pay taxes it's
different the other girls before like
yeah College oh my God I study and I do
exams and I have a bright future and the
other girls are just like I'm a property
manager I make 60k a year and 30 of my
income goes to Texas it's a little bit
of death inside her
yay I don't know maybe it's because I
hit my 30s but whenever I hear a girl
she got hope in her voice my dick gets
soft
because I just feel she's gonna drag me
to a bunch of [__] I don't want to do
the hopeful people stuff well let's go
on a ferris wheel why so we can sit up
in the cold and stare at nothingness
[__] you listen I'm gonna be honest with
you
I'm Skye I'm 21 I'm a full-time student
and I'm also getting my Pilates
certification
I would Define attractiveness by
something that it makes your body feel
like are you attracted to the person or
does it kind of make you repel from them
if you have a great personality you're
fun energetic
the way you said energetic without
energy Ma I love it personally I prefer
somebody who's high energy there's
something about the fact that I can
bring up people's moods just with the
tone of my voice hi okay first off I'm
almost to five here I think we're all
attractive women here should we start
with outfits yes I like her outfit
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not mentioning my dead girl
or not mentioning my desk yo this is
actually cruel
yo not talk about my dead girl and I
thought I was on to something when they
were ignoring the comments she was
making or maybe it was the editing but
now we're watching them at length and
they've already went to four is settled
they left her in fifth she said you
sound like you pay taxes over there
[__]
over here we don't like responsibilities
they don't talk about what's that my
girl is y'all my girl is like Hawaii
because there's Mainland and there's an
island
Hey listen show some love to the Maori
people because this is disrespectful
Maori people are not in Hawaii what are
you doing my God Hey Hey Hey listen
listen when you come with your Geography
okay what you can come in with your
World Knowledge that's not what I'm
talking about but Jesus Christ
have words have meaning and you're not
well places to places to to but guess
what planes exist [__] [__] you the
Maori people can take a plane to Hawaii
if they want to be there I know okay
yeah exactly things are fluid
people are fluid you look fluid yeah
let's keep going and she's just like hey
you know what I'm gonna let y'all talk
cause the the faster we solve this [__]
the fast I could go home to bed and I
gotta work a few years
and this is like it's not playing and
they're doing this whole nice girl thing
where they're just complimenting each
other non-stop would you notice this is
way more mean than the men's episode
look how they've socially completely
isolated homegirl this is foul and this
is what I mean when I say we haven't
played like fake nice with each other a
lot of the times oh my God your hair
your bees blah blah blah blah
but it's what they don't say that some
of the meanest [__] too you get what I'm
trying to say socially they're much more
cruel than men are in my opinion the
dudes will just tell each other nah I'm
not feeling it I think your outfit's
better whatever these women though they
socially killed me and it's really what
you're saying about like it's and what
they don't say yo oh my God it's um
you made an effort
attractive too I almost went to the
Olympics for both ice skating and ski oh
I I go to the gym or mental Clarity and
just to get my physical appearance up
there right now
right shut up
haha
I said Stumpy
yes period but a comma right after back
to us
that's so fast yeah
[Music]
if those personality
character in a good way you two
definitely go up I'm definitely really
quiet
no
yum this is the most cruel episode I've
ever seen
yo this is yo this is the most
cruel episode I have ever witnessed
history
they violated this woman did you see the
way she slid down like oh my God your
personalized so much better than me like
I'm a quiet person and she went up to
the short girl trip I'm not as bad as
you Stumpy anyways like I said from up
here
listen
foreign
all right let's go this video is brought
to you by surf shark no matter where I'm
at all right whether it's uh in my house
or in my Airbnb one on my way or in
Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
Surfside you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have three months extra free
I know crazy
get on it I just talk a lot don't get it
you have such a pretty smile number
Jubilee gotta edit in some Mortal Kombat
fatality sound effects they killing this
girl over and over it feels like you
just seen some roadkill and the [__]
after running over
and then while they're doing it they're
looking at the other girls in the car
back you look so gorgeous girl one
second wait wait wait wait wait
break and put it in one
[Applause]
oh my God your hair yes like I have a
mole right here which is kind of cute
because you're so pretty I know like
sunburn turning red
Whispering because [__] that [__]
anyways
oh my God I feel for you girlfriend
Hey listen if you're watching this you
can hit us up in the DM you get free
tickets when we go on tours yeah that's
my girlfriend you and your boyfriend you
can bring a couple friends yeah I wish I
had your legs
[Laughter]
no questions
you're good at three yeah that girl's
like feels like high school all over
again yeah I feel you my girl
feels like high school for me too
yeah you know what it is true like you
you definitely saw that group of girls
where there was the the one less
attractive girl that they just dragged
along so they can make each other feel
better and she would take it willingly
because she just liked being part of
their group I'm not saying this is this
in this case but it feels similar to
that Dynamic oh yeah the high school
days the way that they're icing her out
is crazy we're not even noticing that
they're doing that like personality came
up and you guys noticed they didn't even
mention her they didn't they all just
went we clearly got better person bro
hold up there was no deliberation there
was a huddle
between them they single they're out I
was expecting myself to be number five
not because I don't think highly of
myself but just because I was on a oh no
like on set with all these beautiful
women and they all have something going
on in their lives too I just feel like
I'm I'm okay what would they set me at
don't even don't even trip you got
yourself a solid career you got yourself
a man go on enjoy your life okay right
now they're in the primary Day School
life they're gonna come out with all
that dead they're gonna try to find a
job a lot of them gonna struggle I ain't
even trying to make you feel it I'm
gonna say that's what it is like out
there they got a lot going on they got a
lot going on for them too but that [__]
hey at least there's worse situations
you could be a mindset coach you know
what I'm saying so let's count our
blessings okay you know what I have an
idea we can hold hands in the world
number one we get a whole hand Hey
listen bro what Hey listen this fake
Kumbaya [__] that women do after
violating someone
it's like being told to hold your
grapes's hand after they get done with
their deed I I don't know women will
straight up just roast the [__] out of
you or pretend like your existence is
useless and then also ask you to be
their friend afterwards that [__] is
disgusting ugh what you mean you want to
hold hands after you left this girl on
an island to die and starve from
dehydration and having to stare at
[__] Wilson
no
she deserves better okay
Wilson the volleyball yeah yeah Cast
Away you catch that reference oh I got
you bro it's for the ogs the old people
young people I don't give a [__] about
you
we're connected
[Music]
if that's my girl there's no way I'm
busting sit on no panel letting her be
violated by five people there ain't no
way we doing a couple of seconds they
gonna put my girl at last that's just
not gonna happen
foreign
they put her last for attractiveness and
they put her last for overall score
that's triple the violation that's like
watching my girl get slapped three times
he didn't they didn't put it in last
place what
in that situation the last place was
fourth place she was not in the
competition they never considered her
nah
um
if I'm walking up and I see my girl
relax I'm like yo shut this [__] down
hey yo shut shut this [__] down [__]
now shut this [__] on the place
yo everybody get on their [__]
knees and y'all getting short of this
stop being this [__]
and then I'm gonna look straight I'm not
gonna be like
baby I love you oh I was a Sam in my low
voice
damn guess what I'd be sipping for my
partner I ain't even gonna lie I'm
supposed to I sit for my daughters I
said for my mom
hey yo
what don't say [__] like that I don't
care I sit for the people in my life
three to four and then uh I think I'd go
buy with the blue socks just because she
is tall and I'm like five seven I'll go
four three two one
I'll start from one I'm gonna say one
um yeah uh two one I ain't stupid
[__] you mean
one I ain't sleeping outside
one I still want a girlfriend
do I do like the Pilates thing I think
that's actually really cool three she's
gonna PhD which is really cool actually
um or I think she's super sweet and then
five nothing against just um not my type
she's still really cool
foreign
I think she's great um has a great
personality it's just not something that
I think I find as subtracting in
particular hey hey shout outs my parents
your personality you look like my
parents
um I would say number five would be her
not my type love the hair though number
four I would say it would be her she's a
little bit on the quiet side ah it's
number three I would say her because
she's a little too tall for me I would
say maybe a lot taller than I am I Love
Her Style love the Long Jacket and of
course number uh number um what was I
it's like five seconds I would say it
would be you not only because she's my
girlfriend but because I just love
simple yeah and that's what made me yeah
she's there
okay
give me two seconds give me two seconds
give me two seconds I got this i got
this
if you were to shut the [__] up just a
little bit more yeah
and they said they'd open the sugar and
like just a little bit more and then you
just tilt her hand a little bit
you've done the whole [__] bag in
there
okay listen there's nothing wrong with
liking a simple partner but after she
just been trashed for this whole time
and everybody putting her a fifth you
saying you like simple and basic just
don't sound good he didn't say basic
he didn't say that
synonyms for simple
plain unadorned undecorated
unembellished uncomplicated Elementary
nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
it seems like a guy's Choice
caught me off guard what'd she say her
being last caught me off guard
yo bro this Show's [__] over why are
you still violating my homegirl yo this
[__] crazy bro this is like after you
win a championship and you have a parade
in your city and then you go in the
arena and score a goal in their goals
yeah
let's throw a second parade let these
[__] know it's not necessary is that
your Arena let me dump [__]
[Music]
um kind of yeah I'm not really sure what
the guys factored in to get there but I
think that the girls have like a more
open-heartedly I can tell you one thing
they definitely did factor in because
they couldn't miss them is some
saber-toothed [__] claws I already
told you guys that shit's a [__] L I
don't know why women still wear those
stupid looking nails but I'm telling you
most men think they're disgusting
because they don't wear it for you
that's what they're gonna say that's
what they're gonna say
I don't think the ranking is based even
on attractiveness I think yeah you just
got put in our places
um I'm not taking anything personally I
mean I still think I'm cute I'm not that
attractive but yeah
what's wrong with this guy
uh I don't even think I'm you know that
attractive but I think I'm all right
damn right babe damn right you you're
[__] all right average is what is
this energy like
like if you think your woman isn't the
most attractive that's fine if you still
love her you find her attractive to you
that's okay you don't have to throw it
out you don't have to be aggressive yeah
damn [__] write you average and I
love you as your little average ass
booty there's that little tiny little
half half Peach yeah [__] average and
I love it five out of ten let's get it
[__]
yeah use a five now we gon get it use it
you don't have to be excited about being
a five
hey uh yo by round of applause who don't
know me here
you don't have to be overly excited
because you don't know who the [__] I am
because
nobody asked for this energy
yo Jennifer I feel for you because you
get violated by everyone and you were
taking it like a champ you're not being
bitter I like that energy I like people
who can take rejection well and be
graceful about it I think it shows a
certain sense of humility humbleness
even though you do get affected and it
can't hurt a little bit not outwardly
projecting it or letting yourself
internalize it without being mean or
Petty afterwards I respect it I think
it's a beautiful quality person and so I
think it's good to highlight that
boyfriend you gotta step that [__] you
gotta figure out a better way to
appreciate your girl you like because it
just sounds like you constantly reminded
everyone's like they're prettier women
out there it's like you don't have to
frame it always that way you know what
I'm saying because I wasn't gonna be
prettier you could just say she's the
one for me and just leave it at that you
don't have to make precisions okay I
don't expect women to be like his dick
is average but it's good enough for me
like if a woman would say some [__] like
that about you how would you take that
[__] I mean he has a small dick but like
that's great that's all my [__] really
wants like oh you can shut the [__] up
that is not a compliment Jesus you can
shut the [__] up about this y'all saying
this on a YouTube video this [__] crazy
bro anyways uh that's it for today's
video that [__] was foul that [__] was
foul foul the way they did my girl was
following and you girls didn't even
notice it oh my God you look amazing you
look gorgeous
and you your hair is stunning it's like
wait I'm right in the middle with [__]
what about me
you don't have nothing I must look
terrible she complimented everyone
except me
you know